et maintenant
les combats à gaza
[Musique]
voici chouchou
[Applaudissements]
ou quelle entrée chez chaumet alors elle
a hâté ça c'est l'entrée comme remettre
à sortir et ça fait plaisir
alors je trouve aussi des rockers comme
si vous êtes là pelli pareil
bonsoir les gens comme moi je parle
comme je voudrais être un ça va
j'adresse à nouveau et juge oui ou en
ouverture tan tan
[Applaudissements]
je connais pas bien la télévision de sa
première télévision en tous les cas je
vais tout vous est l'héroïne d'un film
de merzak allouache s'intituler shufu
ouais nan ça fait mal à la gorge
c'était un petit peu qui sort le 19 mars
comment ça va à sochaux
bon ça va bien alors je dois dire sa
première fois de ma vie je mets les
pieds dans un plan polymorphe à moussan
me sentais bien la science plateau
chabab al samarrai je me sens bien je
suis content comme si j'étais une
vedette alors cup et je vous promets
pour pouvoir
parce que je parle mais je donne le
droit c
[Musique]
si la télé comme la télé c'est la
télévision d'accord ça va alors dit pas
je sérieusement c'est votre vrai prénom
chouchou ça vient des cacahuètes ou des
noeuds pour les cheveux ah non comme m
non c'est un petit dîner à dire quand
même on rigole on rigole mais ça va il
ya des moments peut-être je vais pas
rigoler je suis gentil mais je vais pas
me suis une grande fan
non adhérents je deviens vent à vous
même et à toute la france parce qu à la
france elle regarde de 5 la france
regarde je suis ce soit en même temps je
suis juste un pseudonyme c'est pas mon
vrai nom c'est à dire bah mon vrai nom
c'est choukri et comme j'étais je vais
pas raconter toute ma vie là mais quand
même on m'appelait chouchou parce qu'il
était quelque chose d'affectueux est
facile que choukri
vous connaissez gad elmaleh le moteur du
film
ben si je le connaisse veulent aller
cependant bien avant ah oui et plutôt
sympathique non les sympathiques bon je
peux pas te raconter mais ben may mais
vous l'avez connu comme enjeu si ce
n'est pas indiscret merci ça fait
plaisir
alors là je parle on me donnait la
limonade sellin dorado gad elmaleh je
les connais à la place très léché ah oui
parce que je travaille dans un cabaret
un moment donné je savais qu'il faisait
quand même la malice parce qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui sait tous qu'on y
d'artistes à fouiner à gauche affolé à
droite après si un jour tu te retrouves
dans le film et ils ils allaient ils
allaient à la peau cas où elles allaient
là pour caler avant oui ils sont tous
beaux mecs n'ont quand même
west ham burgos est un beau gosse mais
il a des yeux et la 18 du bichon et vise
les faits sont faux pas
j'ai peur de se voir voler peur lardy
sottise et pourquoi pas parce qu'ils
vivent du mal dans l'arrêt va dire
testing et puis on est beaucoup regardé
au maghreb en algérie en tunisie au
maroc c'est bien d'ailleurs je salue la
maghrebi tout entière aussi d'ailleurs
moi aussi je joue
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous faisiez
avant de faire du cinéma avant de faire
des sédiments ouais j'ai travaillé comme
assistant d'une psychanalyste
je travaille aussi comme serveuse à la
calypso avec un jour rencontrer dijon je
faisais de cocktails gervais les gens je
faisais l'ambiance un gpo vie chante et
peut-être des milliers de chansons je
pouvais être dans une ambiance et une
gaieté qui pourrait laisser entrevoir
que quand même si vous m'arrêtez si à un
moment donné c'est trop lassés jeu
pouvait entrevoir que la vie était belle
dans un élément dans lequel je tombe
bien un cabaret à savoir l'apocalypse la
surprise les gens
des fois je prends le métro avec les 10
10 10 10 les dj comme si j'étais roi
didier manito 10 séance jeux connus
alors smith de l'ambiance et j'aurais
m'a repéré lui peut-il et la lenteur gad
elmaleh et m'a dit je veux faire du
cinéma jeudi mais tu te fous de ma des
médias non pas du tout laisse tomber
l'apocalypse et en avant des dollars
segal cinéma ces familles roms à séville
revient cette année dix langues c'est
léonard a cédé ruraux ouais ouais vous
allez coucher pour réussir
est-ce que j'ai coaché pour réussir oui
non j acques aussi pour vous non
franchement j'ai pas qu'aux si j'ai pas
je suis jamais personne n'a décoché
jamais jamais nous lisez vous l'avez
fait naturellement quoi oui par contre
si je réussis alors là c'est mais je
pourrais aussi beaucoup ça vous fait
quoi je suis sous pouvoir dans un film
sur votre premier clash l'usure l'ardhis
oh oui comme ça mais nathan c'est normal
c'est la première fois que tu viens tout
le monde en parle c'est mes rêves je
sais votre premier film qui vous fait
quoi de vous retrouver dans un film
bon franchement je te jure quand j'ai vu
la première fois au cinéma je disais
c'est quand même quelque chose
d'incroyable d'état soit le cinéma tu
vois pas tête qui bouge toi même à moi
même je me regarde
bon je sais pas quand même quelqu'un qui
aime trop dessus voire j'aime a pu dire
j matin midi et a alors fait c'est la
dégringolade l'art
j'en ai bien peur je sais c'est quoi
l'histoire le film raconte votre vie
d'une certaine façon à aider rigoler 1
ce festival 44 44
l'épée de damoclés ça ne s'est pas
franchement non je vais par les
dirigeants j'aime pas le même poids sur
la table je n'aime pas les gens qui se
moquent
c'est ce que pointe du doigt vengeur et
j'y suis bien j'ai pas envie non mais
solide en respectant les stands mais ça
va on est parent n'est pas en pièces oui
je suis ce film ça parle de quoi ça
raconte de vie ça raconte ma vie c'est
en hommage à ma vie que je suis venu du
maghreb xj6 de m'intégrer que j'ai
rencontré l'amour j'ai assez mes mains
mon âme social est repris de manière
tout à fait libérale parce qu'on m'a
pointé du doigt j'y suis ici d'une
culture où le succès les tailles comme
un tabou laisse tomber je vous le fais
pas dire
vas-y souilah regarde pas je dis
attention je dis attention les gens
surtout dans une période en ce moment de
crise où le monde cynique le monde est
ironique il faut de la cohérence mais il
faut du droit à la différence et me faut
un troisième mois en france la merci
beaucoup
nouveauté
et votre amant dans le film alain chabat
c'est un bon coup à faire beaucoup
oh ça va pas trop bien un bon qu a
beaucoup bon je peux pas dire un bon
coup même si j'ai vécu des choses et sur
la place publique je peux pas me griller
une façon ces films est maintenant bien
ses fils mais mais mais quand même elle
embrasse comme de manière à bois tamoul
et à quel jeu joue avec les avec les
moustaches barbes aux pages cet été il
est est ce que depuis le tournage du
film vous n'êtes pas un petit peu
jalouse de file du winter non parce que
ben moi je le vois la journée ouais je
crois la voile est oui oui oui
maintenant que stan équilibre au moins
comme moi même je n'ai pas très jalouse
de la félibrée routeur parce que j'ai eu
moi-même je chante
oui moi même et ceux capables d'envoûter
des mélopées à n'importe quelles
conséquences
je ne suis pas je ne suis pas jaloux du
talent des autres jupes eu moi même pour
une occasion de préciser au même
aléatoire me laisser aller à la musique
à leur attention
[Applaudissements]
non
maintenant je suis chaud une question
très importante et comme vous êtes
devenu une star mais vous en poser
souvent des comme ça
si brad pitt vous proposer de faire un
film avec lui
est-ce que vous accepteriez brad mexique
et soit la pratique
brad pitt déjà j'aime pas trop si aux
lorrains
brad pitt très franchement jb oui moi je
sais pas ce que ça va être pratique et
john deere on n'est que des sketchs que
je connais personnellement et aux autres
acteurs que vous connaissez pas moi ce
qui est important sur le scénario mais
c'est l'association dans laquelle on va
me mettre d'accord et contrairement à
beaucoup d'actrices françaises qui va
commencer à vous prendre la tête avec
elle le personnage tout ça ouais si
aussi l'implication personnelle que je
vais faire et j'aimerais mettre un autre
point sur la table car depuis quelques
temps je suis devenu intermédiaire du
spectacle ah bon je vais problème
maintenant un jeu j'y viens j'aimerais
mettre au grand jour et sur la place
publique des problèmes que vivent les
intermédiaires des spectacles qui sont
très importants en tant qu'intermédiaire
dix spectacles je trouve que c'est pas
normal et loin de moi un discours qui va
dire pourquoi on donne toujours aux
maghrébins des rôles de maghrébins non
ma question c'est pourquoi tout le temps
dit rôle des femmes on les donne aux
femmes arrivées et l'érotisme en étant
nous sommes
est ce que vous voulez
un hacker de caméras pour garder votre
caméra je veux lancer l'appel contre pas
prendre par exemple les thèmes connus
comme les trams oui par exemple
comprends mais pas menée sur alors
qu'ils auraient pu prendre cette femme
voilà donc que les deux clous de la
lauch qu'est ce qu'elle fait elle va
faire à nommer une femme à qui les
besoins nationaux
trois hommes un conte fait qu est ce qu
elle après un copain et trois ans
bonjour l'imagination vive la france
veut tomber attends tu joues excusez-moi
fléchi sous un seul film vraiment qui a
fait preuve de tolérance dans le cinéma
c'est beethoven car ils ont pris un
chien mais vous arrivez vous arrivez de
magret dit est-ce que c'est difficile
d'être homosexuel dans votre pays
chouchou très bien entendu alors la
laisse tomber les gens vous juge vous
regarde vous montre du doigt
ça dépend du qu'elle sait c'est pas
demain cc c'est pas demain qu'on aura
une une vieille pride à marrakech fois
need a craqué ton slip tort je sais pas
moi non je pense pas franchement non je
ne pense pas pour l'instant il faut un
épanouissement encore beaucoup plus
important car non pas pour l'instant tu
joues en tant que marocaine est ce que
vous êtes prête à partir en guerre
contre les pointes sèches et les cheveux
cassants
[Musique]
ces petits symboles est oui un peu
insolente même sur une solitaire si je
pars je partir en guerre ben pas celle
que qui nous menacent la presse que si
je peux te dire que celle là alors là
les stands et si dieu veut mais j'étais
prête à partir en guerre pour les
pointes sèches qui suivent cas sont
toutes sortes de combats cellulite
alors là si les notes pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas
si vous aviez un mot à dire à tous les
travestis du monde ce soit chouchou ça
serait quoi
j'aimerais dire la bombe donne une
occasion de pouvoir m'exprimer je suis
désolé des parce que vous m'avez touché
qu'on voudrait ça q j'aimerais qu'ils
vivent leur personnalité leur identité
comme il veut et que tous les gens au
monde qui nous regardent maintenant
qu'ils se sont différents eh ben ça fait
plaisir qu'il avait vous promet le veux
tu en voilà
sous fifres isolé un député c'est une
émission de la rigolade peut-être c'est
ça non mais c'est une émission de temps
en temps on est capable de dire des
choses très sérieuses et jaune est le
message que vous faites passer ce soir
c'est un message de de la gym bien votre
mon jetage à l'espagne et la zone
darbary non ça me fait passer un message
de de différence de tolérance de là il
me manque un mot ans mais vive la france
vive la france
je joue qu'est-ce qui est le plus dur
aujourd'hui c'est d'être une femme ou de
ne pas être une femme je crois vous
touchez un point très délicat très
sensible vous remuez quelque part et
chez moi dit choses très fortes
je crois qu'il peut dire s'il ne pas
avoir étrenné comme une femme car c'est
un combat de tous les jours et par un
que moi beaucoup de gens les tabous sont
là les gens vous jugent donc si de ne
pas être une femme qui est vraiment un
vrai combat
[Musique]
non
soit
[Musique]
très émouvant je suis je crois que c'est
une séquence très émouvante mais ça sert
c'est un moment de télé hein y'a que sur
la télé qu'on peut avoir ça je choque at
il de plus féminin du film henin peut
être bon pour parler sérieusement et à
ma sensibilité
ouais
et peut-être dudit parti du parti des
dix deuxième partie de soirée
ichou
qu'y at il de plus masculin en vaut
[Rires]
toujours du plus masculin le bon
j'essaye de le refouler
mais peut-être que du plus masculin
c'est ma détermination ma motivation
et quand je dis quelque chose je peux te
dire qu'ils essaient mandat vous
entendrez me avec les hommes avec les
femmes avec des tables oui il n'ya pas
du tout de la tuer mais je peux la
comprendre pour un con si je peux lui
donner des avis personnel je peux te l'a
retourné la tête en 10 secondes
un homme un homme si facile ouais
l'homme est très manipulable
non contrairement il plaît les machos et
plus et dégonfler comme ça hein
les plus petits plus de r mais sauf
l'homme sensible attention donc sensible
intelligent l'homme qui l'a senti vis
des pays qui sait devenir saint servais
exacerbée merci est ce que ça vous
montre que je suis fou de ne plus
pouvoir faire pipi debout
alors attention je contredis cette chose
car je me croyais et je veux pas rentrer
dans l'intimité
non je n'ai pas suivi encore avant mais
avec le cachet que j'ai perçu du cmr je
ferai un voyage
dans les cantines lointain si vous étiez
un homme jechoux quel genre de femme
vous attirerez madonna on a pour moi
c'est le comble de la sexualité à
outrance ah ouais je vous trouvez que
c'est celle qui a l'air le plus [__]
quoi bon je n'irai pas ce que la paris
design et en algérie au maroc et me
regarde cette heure ci ouais mais c'est
une grosse chaleur peut que j'aime bien
quand on est tous d'accord
ben oui il n'y a pas de discussion élevé
c'est agréable à regarder
je suis votre style donne c'est quoi mon
style d'homme c'est plutôt qu'on a tu
dirais daniel auteuil a boosté les
banques qui comme un peu mystérieux qui
est pas trop exubérant même tenté
centrer mais qui sait où il va ce qu'il
est seul en ce moment gagné à la balle
et celle en ce moment attention ugolin
[Applaudissements]
soleil capitaine
d'un bâton
mais
laon
et
pas
[Musique]
non
le temps
[Musique]
je t'en ailles en voyant
au piment fort et larmor dans la plage
ça ouais chouchou des choses
[Applaudissements]
vous arrêtez vous demande de vous
arrêter
je joue comment pourrais-je vous séduire
vous oui moi je suis très romantique
mais aussi alors bon j'adore renifleurs
jouer lille études upe dit que les
mimosas sauf les orchidées les heures
qui dit c'est ma [__] noir ça je touche
où vous vous faites quelque chose après
l'émission
tu sais quoi ouais rendez vous randy vos
après les meilleurs ouah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aimerais vous décorer
[Applaudissements]
le temps
aux jeunes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il va
reuter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avant de recevoir mon invité